12 7 The skills I’ve accumulated are just studying and rock school. In fact
, I wasn’t good at this
kind of thing.
I chose it
13 years ago I was also in a large store, and about 10 employees had a suitable 0 3 6
5 And
it says I will do this by myself Uh I just really worked.
It's more than hard work or hard work.
Of course, if you succeed at a hair salon that big
, you can get a lot of fame and a lot of money.
The
result is what Jang is
talking about, so when I'm working, I'm nervous and only focus on consulting, but
I think there's no perfect skill,
so it's the worst when customers are disappointed.
It's been 12 hours with as many people as possible going out
, but I got at least 10 customers and now I'm alone and I get 1 save
.
It's
good to do everything I can.
My parents and I see them as my enemies. My brother and I are very
individual and neutral.
I tried to twist things a lot. My parents forced me to do things I didn’t want to
do, and I had a lot of problems
.  It's a bit of an
icy doctor's memory of saying the name because it's difficult
. It's right on the road.
There are cases where men are rather shy about going to a big hair salon.
same hand  I think I avoided it a lot before you brought me. I
thought it was meaningless. There were things I couldn't do if I was the only one living well,
but I
felt very empty.
I think the truth can be overwhelming, but
I don't want to live in a hot country. I'm
a person who thinks that I can't eat when I die, so I want to live in a different culture and
find out more in another space, so I'm worried about living for real.
I'm still doing this,
but won't it be like that for the rest of my life?